hi guys Greg Alba here and it's John
over here so we're going to talk about
the Wonder Woman early reaction in a
huge tomato score on Rotten Tomatoes so
many to make before we go into that
though we want to give a shout out to
today's video sponsor TV time we go to
TV time calm or if you download the app
the TV time app it's available on iPhone
or Android and honestly we get a lot of
offers we get a lot of offers to talk
about apps you get the best of you and
the best off as getting it and leave me
to the best your going to love these
products we get we get so many offers or
we don't agree to every single one of
them yet but this one is an app that is
perfectly in line with something that a
we would both use and then I already
started using today be it's something
that I think all you guys would love to
use as well and that's what I'm being
very genuine about that yeah we have to
pitch for this and pretty much
immediately really critic help yeah we
just create an account while we're here
in the pitch yeah and basically what TV
time does is it allows you to keep track
of all your favorite shows even down to
the episode yeah you can keep track of
your progress it'll tell you when
episodes of your favorite shows are
coming up and as a calendar it's very
much broken down like to give you an
example today I went into I've been
watching the show arrow catching up on
all the CW shows my gold is here's to
watch all the CW shows we've watched a
lot more TV than we actually make
reviews and shows because that's more of
our personal little side thing we don't
want to keep reviewing them for us but I
thought like people are constantly asked
I get a lot of tweets asking like what's
going on with where you add an arrow and
stuff so right now I'm on episode 15 of
arrow I just watched it and I get a
little comment about it but the cool
thing is instead of just leaving
comments you can leave memes gifts you
could take photos and on top of that too
you could also do like reactions to it
you can record a video and give a quick
little review or commentary or a little
snippet on the video so you can have
reactions as well so I'm going to be
using that for every single episode I
watch on TV from here on out oh yeah
because we're watching daredevil
together and I'm showing that to him
also watching so watch a lot of things
or NEP yes so hopping around so I think
you guys should go get that app
because a lot of people are using it and
it's actually really cool and it allows
you to stay updated with everything
inputs you could hear our opinions on
show's over currently watching oh yeah I
mean there's more TV than you could ever
watch right now for so especially for me
like the ability you have to keep that
to organize and keep track of the shows
that you like their interfaces terrific
and you can add you can create the ECAM
where you can add the show so that way
you have a whole list of all the shows
are watching or you can see all the
shows that we added so you can see what
we've watched or what we're currently
watching and so go to the description
box is a link there you get down an
iPhone Android or go to the website and
create an account and follow us at the
real Regis other one word all right
let's talk about Wonder Woman boy oh boy
oh man Wonder Woman come out five
percent of the worst DC yeah quite the
opposite John rotten tomatos has given
it a 9-mil seven percent as one hundred
and ninety seven percent recorded this
video it's at a ninety seven percent
rotting tomatoes are just DC fanboys
hand-paint marble and I think Marvel
fans should start petitioning because
guardians of the galaxy is lower
percentage score than Wonder Woman
currently I think Marvel should start
petitioning that they're just biased
yeah for DC I know Rogers Madoka they
got paid by DC yeah it's a hate on
Marvel and things Warner Brothers owns
Rotten Tomatoes yeah oh yeah they made
hundreds and hundreds of critics to go
and say nice things about it all over
the internet so yeah it's all BS yeah
obvious is a horrible thing no that's
where all that ad money goes we've
talked to you a lot of it beyond the
early Twitter reactions that you've seen
online we met up with a lot of people
who've seen the movie and who really
loved the film we've spoken with humans
human beings you in the name as you
might know we're book free embargo being
lifted with everyone everyone at the
same time what the embargo was lifted
I got like seven donations through
everyone has a review a little savings
effects of blood
and everyone's loving the film and I'm
genuinely very happy for the DCE you
they're really much ham because this is
a monumental achievement for comic book
movies the reason being is this even
though BBS and Suicide Squad were not
the most well received films and Marvel
is known to have the reputation for
having the better Congress movies in
general the DC EU even if they have even
if their next film is crap even if from
now on all their films but they will
always have the Cygnus the one great
female-driven
comic-book movie and that's something
that's monumental because for the
longest time we needed a great superhero
female lead in it and Wonder Woman is a
hard film to bring to the big screen
well it's arguably the definitive female
superhero absolutely but what is think
of it is it's like even if you asked on
a name of a legit female superhero
you're most likely you're going to list
off Wonder Woman even if you haven't
like read comics or seen shows you know
Wonder Woman so the fact that they
nailed this and even if even though we
haven't seen it so we don't have an
opinion on the actual film itself yet
the fact that the majority of people the
general consensus is that people are
loving it that is something to be said
that is something monumental because now
they have this film that is just
definitive so no matter what films come
out next after the DCE you just asleep
it's such going to be like no matter
what you could always say well they had
the first great female superhero movie
well yeah and I mean this is a big
moment for that I mean of all the things
for them to nail I feel like this is
kind of the best one and it's funny that
it should be Wonder Woman is the one for
the DCU if not turns things around at
least Garner's them some praise because
you know you go back to VBS and those
are very sort of hyper masculine yeah I
need a Suicide Squad is that way so to
have Wonder Woman come on Bettina and it
sounds like they really nailed it is
just gratifying yeah as a person who
watches a lot of these movies and
looking at and we know Rotten Tomatoes
doesn't mean everything I know but you
know right now and your latterly
reaction is the best thing to go off
over there right now yeah
totally and I mean we saw a couple clips
like like we said from this and and
those alone got us Korean excited and
it's waged a lot of the stresses we were
feeling coming off of the previous film
because right now the consensus at as
were filming this for current consensus
I have 66 reviews 64 fresh to a rotten
and the consensus is thrilling earnest
boy oh boy
Bowie Bowie sorry boy why can I say that
Bowie new by gal gadot godot's
charismatic performance when a woman
succeeds in spectacular fashion as I
skimmed through like all these consensus
all the other little castles that they
have here it seems to be the perfect
superhero film based off with everyone's
am hoping I love it as much instead of
making it out to be I mean the only
complaints I've seen across all these
capsules is just a couple sailing yeah
towards the end it gets really big in
third act heavy yeah but that's that is
whatever you want to do it doesn't
bother me because that's what most comic
book movies 10.if most conv movies when
they have an issue it tends to be the
third act yeah and it just tends to be
the third act is too big and it out and
you know it loses some of the nuances
but the what's been so inspiring about
reading some of these capsules is that a
lot of people are pointing out that it
brings a lot of new flavors and a lot of
new yeah nuances to the superhero
formula and a common thing I'm hearing
too is that there's an energy in life
that you feel by the time it's done you
want more instead of feeling exhausted
you feel someone says I'm feeling like
you want to kill yourself it's good
feeling exhausted you feel uplifted you
feel like you had a rollicking good time
wonder and I'm so happy for a gal gadot
because I'll be honest when I first
heard she was cast in it I wasn't um I
wasn't a hater
who is it John Campea to be honest
someone put together that felt so bad
for John Campea and I'm going to promote
the video right now when intentionally
yeah
there's no quick the energetic election
eclipse outline of John Campea just
talking so much smack on go
go and wonder open oh no like just to
the announcements and everything I
wasn't like that and a lot of people
were and Beyond junkie and the reason
why I'm like I have nothing against John
Campea saying that because a lot of
people were saying things similar to
what he was saying I know if you
especially wonder woman fans who saw BBS
at least and said like no way she's not
my Wonder Wheel yeah yeah exactly so
they see that most people especially the
critics are saying that she does an
amazing job that makes me really happy
for her yeah because she had a lot going
against her and patty Jenkins is Emma
and she continues that streak of casting
someone who you wouldn't expect to be it
you know you get Charlize Theron for
monster this beautiful gorgeous model
yet real-life disturbing serial killer
Eileen Turner and she does it a
fantastic job I don't think she was the
one who hired gal gadot Mademoiselle
hunter but she's still under patty
Jenkins direction for this entire
feature film and to see that gal gadot
still in it you know despite all
preconceived notions of oh you don't
really look like the comic book Wonder
Woman we all imagine but the fact that
everyone is loving her that makes me so
happy for her I always love it when the
underdog gets a chance to really shine
gets a chance to to win over everyone
because of a performance a lot of
preconceived physical experience well
some of the some of the comparisons to
the Richard Donner Superman have me
feeling really good because I've been
missing that that spirit a lot from
these me and the heroic tale and Patti
James when we saw the qat
she constantly talked about how her
biggest influence for making this film
was Richard Donner Superman to go way
back to the 70s and make that og like
type of Flair and style to it which is
so exciting and what better film to take
influence from then that Superman one if
you're going to if you're going to
introduce Wonder Woman to us yeah well
it's always cool we saw Q and a Q&A with
patty Jenkins we screamed it on our
Facebook feed but it's always fun when
you see the reviews start to pop up and
like a lot of the things the director
says they were going for show up in
those Yahoo's and like well done seems
like you've really nailed this one
and I'm wondering now because I mean is
the DC use and rather experimental thank
you given that
yeah it was another's ever been generic
its outer threat they've been rather
experimental and it hasn't been panning
out the greatest in terms of like the
overall consensus for everyone
seeing that patty that's what also to
make this monumental the first superhero
film about a female superhero and also
directed by a lady to be directed by a
female they've created his movie history
by making a great film which is operas
most likely gonna be a big box office
smash fit now oh yeah I can't I mean
there's already was going to be but I
imagine even more now with word-of-mouth
that is going to be even making a lot
more money I wouldn't be my best BBS I
don't know the backlash said that
all-female screenings at one screening
they didn't often I bet a lot of people
are going to go now because they're
really upset about it really looking
back gonna kill all times those people
are going to kill the business net
feminism is on the rise men suck that's
real feminism look at what it's all
about it's all about taking rights away
from men yeah that's not a
better-quality thought about women
having equal rights it's about putting
the men down and bringing the woman up
don't read a book or do any research you
know just hear a word outside what it
means it is not exactly how this all
works and one thing I'm looking forward
to as well the trailers don't give you a
good idea of the villain and even though
I heard the third act is a little muddy
little comic book movie yeah I still
hear the villain is really good in the
film as well and that makes me excited
because I mean if you're going to do
like dte you versus MCU MCU still not
known to have the greatest villains but
a lot of people walk out the same two
villain in this is pretty damn good
actually
yeah you got a greatest your gun out
here yeah how do Jake should take over
the DCE if she's headed
she's right is it every man from here on
actually be the Joss Whedon of the DCE
over Geoff Johns caddies world and - I
like the advertising for this actually
now I think about it in hindsight
because I don't have a tremendous sense
for the villain so to speak but what I
think they have builds up and what they
sold this movie based on is wonderful
yeah look getting to know Wonder Woman
and and CN forever is getting a lot of
praise - yeah I mean just from that
little scene we saw there interplay
terrific I mean both in the comic timing
and also just in their teamwork yeah
sure in chemistry yeah I'm excited to
see this yeah this is this is the one DC
film that once I started seeing trailers
for it I've had close to no doubts other
than I mean the other ones aren't that
great but the trailers already sold me
there now and I was doing videos
constantly exclaiming this one will be a
good film this live in saying that
confidently at this one I feel will be a
good film and even if I don't like it
that's right even if I watch it is
Thursday and I don't end up liking it
I'm still going to feel glad that
everyone else is really loved it didn't
happy for you did was really happy that
you guys are doing well cuz I don't know
I didn't feel the DC EU is dim it was
more like what the hell are you guys
doing right now it was more of that like
what are you doing right now but this
seems like the right direction ago and I
hope that from here on out their films
continue to be solid yeah hopefully I
mean I don't know what stars aligned in
the making of this movie and and there
was that report that came out a couple
months ago a little Wonder Woman yes -
you know we don't know exactly what's
happened behind the scenes of these
movies maybe they just tampered less
with this or maybe there was more time I
know they brought it wasn't it the first
thing Geoff Johns really worked on with
them and yet overall leg I think halfway
through the production well the thing is
patty Jenkins though she said that
there's not a single deleted scene and
that they let her make the movie she
really wanted to make because that's the
game they were talking with the DCE you
all along and you see Suicide Squad and
see BBS and you wonder if that's true
the whole like we know we want we don't
want committees we want filmmaker driven
film CVS and Suicide Squad both give off
the impression that they said that and
didn't mean it because they all feel
like nobody made them some nebulous
organization kind of threw them together
in a blender and between hearing patty
Jenkins talk and now seeing this it
seems like yeah she she had a confident
vision that she conveyed to us in the QA
and it sounds like it really came
through here so if they found a way to
make their creator driven movie work
yeah that bodes well in the future for
me and then thinking about down the line
what guys like James Wan who is more
than
capable of this kind of movie yeah it
does give me some hope yeah I'm thinking
that I mean they just started filming
Aquaman there's a lot of films BCD you
have slated to film that haven't begun
filming yet and I'm wondering that now
with this film getting such great
feedback if at all they're going to take
influence from what Wonder Woman did and
apply it to their future installments
especially the ones that haven't been
filming so no justice Lee was already
shot at another going back you know
after Zack Snyder has to leave the
project due to personal reasons Joss
Whedon stepping in and taking care of
post and also filling in a couple of
other like little reshoots not like big
reshoots whatever but that one's pretty
much done but I'm wondering it after
Justice League all the films that I have
are not yet finished filming or are they
going to film they'll take influence and
lessons from what Wonder Woman did so
well yeah and really make it make find
it's right tone because the Marvel films
did that smart where they they found
they found the right tone with most of
their films here I'm hoping that they
find the right type of spirit as well
yeah totally you know I I said
confidently leading into this movie that
I would believe it when I see ya and I
still kind of feel that way about DC
moving forward but it does make me a
little more hopeful that you know now
that I know that it seems as though they
can get it right or get it to a place
where most people yes very good moving
forward a little more awesome idea but
being away even of all DC even the DC u
films end up being bad after Wonder
Woman and Lisa Nene's day a date at
least they got the one defining film
they could have gotten a Batman film
right but it wouldn't have been a
special of it lamo achievement you can
have some email directing a female
superhero star and one in a comic book
movie arguably yeah this is the one you
can afford the lease to myself it's like
the one that no other studio Marvel
included doesn't have this is a major
opportunity and I'm glad they took it
that series is something special I'm
glad everyone's loved it can't wait to
see it this week after we watch it we're
going to watch it like a really late
night showing on Thursday we're probably
going to be tired when the movies done
so we'll probably will have a review up
by Friday alright guys well thanks for
tuning in you guys can go subscribe to
the real
Ajax click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of Blum house comm
you can go check out our patreon where
we have a lot of exclusive content on
there a lot of awesome rewards for you
know the lowest pledge tears possible go
check it out and we're having a blast
over there actually going to film a Q&A
for the patreon community right now yeah
much love to everyone keep a lookout for
Wonder Woman review check out their TV
time app Marvel sucks